[Music]
conita was a food desert
but i wanted to do something about it
we begin to grow
and we begin to put our hearts and hands
together and canada is no longer a food
desert pinita is a food oasis
[Music]
i'm reverend richard arjuna founder of
conita family life center
kenita is a rural area in the eastern
part of north carolina population about
300 people
a food doesn't really mean that the
residents here do not have access to
fresh locally affordable grown foods we
buy most of our food from discount
stores which are high in sodium calories
very low nutritional values
people had these early stages of chronic
disease diabetes high blood pressure
heart attacks strokes
and even mental illness because of the
stress and some pain
people dying in their 30s and 40s we
would be having two to three funerals a
month and really devastating families
[Music]
i was really feeling overwhelmed and
feeling hopeless because i couldn't stop
this chronic disease
i pulled inside the road and really
started praying
wanting to know what could i do
and i had this epiphany of open your
eyes look around
and i lowered my eyes and all i saw was
fields
[Music]
so we started our first small garden
and now we're up to 21 acres of farmland
we have about eight people that are
parents and grandparents of our youth
that work here every day we have 40
students during the summer
that use this farm for their reading
writing math and science and for food
presently on our farm we have
blueberries tomatoes we have collards we
have squash we have zucchini
we end up averaging 100 pounds of food
per week out of the garden
food that we grow has had a tangible
impact upon our community
we're able to put food on people tables
hello every best of us all right
our community is spending four thousand
dollars less a month on prescription
pills because of the food
the deaths have slowed down we're not
having as many funerals i feel like we
are making a difference
i love this community here because
we're united around
saving lives together
[Music]
you